[Music]
foreign
thank you so much for joining me thank
you for having me
it's good to be here yeah we met er wow
gosh it was
six years ago could it be five years ago
four years ago and it's been four years
already uh unbelievable eh
you know so we met at the forbes 30
under 30 and
photo shoot which was a quite a quite a
spectacular experience
and since then we've been friends and
i've been following your journeys around
the world
from pursuing a fourth degree set in law
and and your your various lectures
based on also your experience back in
the army as a fighter as a soldier as a
leader
and how you're bridging it all together
now to think
more broadly about human rights and
democracy i don't even know how to begin
please just take it away and start
telling me a little bit about yourself
all right so um i'll start by saying
that
it's really good to be here and you know
you said you're following me and it's
totally mutual
um besides the fact i feel i'm getting
too older because it's been four years i
haven't even thought of this
i'm full of appreciation to what you do
in this initiative which is great it's
always good to expose uh the methods
and and schools of thoughts of different
leaders from different backgrounds so i
think it's great
uh as far as for me so as you said i was
i was very fortunate and lucky to be
part of the ford's under 30 list
which is where i met you as well um ever
since
uh i would say that my professional time
is basically
divided to four i am
a lawyer no one's perfect so i advise
my specialties is constitutional law and
international also i advise
on this different aspects to certain
entities
um i'm a phd candidate i'm currently
pursuing my fourth law degree
following my degrees from tel aviv
university and nyu school of law
i'm pursuing my phd in law from tel aviv
university
uh i'm not gonna overload you with what
i am doing my phd on because
you don't want anyone to fall asleep
right now i'm just gonna say it is
related to war
but it's not that interesting to people
who are not like from the legal sphere
um completing the book these days i know
it sounds like a cliche because i'm
completing this book for the past year
and a half now
but uh due to covet 19 i have the
ability to actually be at home and
get things done right very very close to
complete the book
the book evolves my team's experiences
from operation cast lead
from gaza in 2008
it is a memoir i do not go into legal
analysis on the book
where i do go into legal analysis is my
fourth
dimension of professional sphere which
is
the talks and the lectures that i give
worldwide
what i do in this talks i usually speak
about what i call my dual perspective on
war
human attorney and as a special forces
veteran um
basically what i do is sharing real
scenarios that my teammates and i
have gone through um i would explain how
the laws of
war view those situations the geneva
convention the head regulations
yeah and then i would share what we did
in real life
yeah and the purpose is double to
emphasize the complexity and also
to to stress what i call the high
standards of the idea
but not from a blind advocacy point of
view but rather from
what i'm trying to do more to bring a
more articulated point of view
into the discussion so now that this is
basically what
i don't even know where to take it from
here so i'm just going to go with
intuition
can you can you give me a little bit of
a teaser about
about what what you went through as a
leader and as a fighter
and in and around gaza and how that
translates into your broader thinking of
of of what it means law legal
regulations
contracts human rights et cetera
it's a terrific question um i'll tell
you this
um i'm not sure i was a leader
in gaza in gaza i was part of a team
i was equal to everyone else we were
13 brothers from different mothers each
and every one of us had a role
where i do find leadership uh in this
equation
is where i took it um in my civilian
lives
into together those experiences that
have that i've uh witnessed firsthand
and try to deliver a cohesive
balanced narrative towards our country
our homeland israel
these experiences had led me to
understand two things regarding
leadership number one
is that you constantly have to be
critical towards
any law that you view uh time and again
we
talk with each other intercourse about
different laws and what we think about
them but
rarely have we criticized their
origins what do they ought to really
accomplish
and when you take a complex situation
such as war
and you bring to an audience
and it doesn't matter what kind of
audience by the way we can talk about
the different audiences that i'm engaged
with
but you bring these laws to an audience
and on paper
if they are you know as my nyu
professors tend to call them they are
celebrated laws they look great on paper
but then but then in the money time yeah
in money time you you emphasize to
people what they allow you to do
these are some terrible stuff terrible
things and you can obviously sympathize
with that because you've served in the
military you're an officer if you
know a thing or two about um difficult
experiences so in terms of leadership
talking about these issues has led me to
realize i have to constantly
be in a critique
point not in a rebellious mode but to
constantly question and also to to
deliver this modest operandis
this way of thinking uh to other people
and i think in the larger a sense of of
the experience
look i was very fortunate to engage with
a lot
of communities worldwide uh
i've delivered i would say by
by now hundreds of lectures in the past
three years
to communities all over the world north
america
i've spoken to palestinians in brazil
people in hungarian north america
australia
israel of course and you see the
diversity of people
and in terms of leadership i've
understood
a few things number one
in terms of the jewish people we are a
very diverse
people very diverse yet i happen to be
one of those
israelis who believe that the fact that
i have a blue id card israeli id card
does not make israel more mind that it's
not yours and specific because you are
an israeli
uh but yeah it doesn't make it more
mine than other jews who are
non-israelis in this sense i truly
believe that we are all part of
the same zionist project and each and
every one of us is holding the structure
from a different angle
it does not mean that israel is not a
home for other
nationalities and ethnicities it is a
jewish and
a democracy but um i've learned that at
the end of the day despite the the
controversies and the lack of agreements
within the jewish people
and you know the joke put three twos in
a room you're gonna have 12 different
opinions
i know 24 different opinions exactly i
think only in this conversation we have
six different opinions
so despite the the lack of consensus in
the jewish world regarding any
everything um
there are still common denominators and
common goals we are trying to achieve
and i think by the way it's very
symbolic we're talking about this today
it's you know it's the holocaust
memorial day um
not trying to be over dramatic but
engaging in all these communities has
really made me realize that there is
eventually a true combat denominator
among the jewish people
and even largely speaking look
um i've engaged with non-jews as well of
course i'm
more than happy to engage with any
community
or entity uh that would love to hear me
speak
and look people are eventually the same
i think i said the same thing in my nyu
convocation speech
it doesn't really matter where you're
from everyone wants the same basic
things at the end of the day
we want health especially today in the
age of covert 19 we want happiness
we want self-fulfillment fulfillment and
i think it's fascinating to meet so many
people from all over the world get to
understand that everyone is very similar
uh at the end of the day um and i'm sure
you're you're sharing the same uh
experiences now at stanford yeah when
you're
you're a minor party is not there coming
from a very small country in the middle
east the size of new jersey
a very controversial one that is as well
not just tiny and
small gotti talk to me a little bit
about democracy
and a fight for democracy and a
struggle for that uh
it's a big question do you have a year
or two
uh i'll give you i'll give you three if
you can give me an answer for that but
yeah
look um i'll just say this without
getting into
politics of course right
it's really interesting we're talking
about this in times of
global pandemic
um human rights
the challenge of of keeping and
preserving human rights is primarily in
times of crisis
no right is absolute no right even the
right for life you know sometimes we
allow to to kill other people either
either if it's within uh the concept of
war
or criminal law when we execute people
in certain legal systems
uh but the true challenge of keeping
democracy alive is
especially in in times of emergency uh
israel is under a constant
uh situation of emergency since the day
we have established in 1948
the world right now is in a in a global
emergency situation i think it's
tremendously interesting to see how the
world is gonna evolve
oh yeah from this uh what rights are
gonna remain fundamental human rights
what are we in the legal community that
have to say about things such as privacy
you know both you and i agree that it's
crucially important for example to
combat the virus
and and you know some of us have no
problem
to give the authorities access to our
mobile phones
now i'm not saying if it's good or bad
i'm just saying
it's really interesting to see if after
this ends and
then this will end at some point you
know this virus is gonna
yeah go away how are we gonna view
different rights such as the right for
privacy for example
are we gonna go back to ground zero of
you know
of the right privacy as we deem it right
now or are we gonna
witness certain changes and i think it's
a fascinating constitutional
international law discussion
these times uh are facing
making us face tremendous challenge and
you know what they say in the legal
community um hard law makes
uh uh hard cases i'm sorry makes that
law
uh the challenge of the international
community right now
uh would be not to make bad law this
really hard piece
you know yeah one of the one of the
things that just you know really
distraught me was i i read a piece by
yuval no harari
when he was contemplating the potential
the significant implications of a lot of
these
you know very quick decision that we're
doing you know so you mentioned
surveillance and
and our willingness to allow a
government to be able to track us you
know for our own benefit at this point
and one of the things that he was
contemplating was yes we are now
sort of blinded in this bubble of a
pandemic but we have to think to remind
ourselves that
what's happening the day after the
pandemic and what social norms are we
changing here
and what new baselines are we setting
for ourselves
and which you know a lot of these
decisions
uh would have taken months of
deliberation in a congress
or a parliament to discuss and all of a
sudden in a matter of hours
everybody agrees to them and it's it's
really fascinating
but you know if you think about it
michael there's a reason why the legal
system the constitution in a given
country
allows the government to do that within
matters of hours
sometimes we need to do it in a matter
of hours um
i i say that the truth is somewhere in
the middle you need to allow a
government to function
um yet you cannot constantly be
with your head stuck in the ground
thinking just about
right now totally you have to balance
and integrate both the short-term
thinking and the long-term thinking
going back to the beginning of our talk
it's very similar to kinetic war
um time and again i'm being asked in my
talks
wait uh so if there is if a soldier is
in a
in a given situation shouldn't
he or she take into account
the way a target killing would be
perceived by
the media or the way a target killing
for example would be perceived by the
international criminal court in the
hague yes
okay and my constant answer is that the
country the system
needs to take all the considerations
into account
but the question is the question of
deviation of responsibilities
uh i'm not sure that the the job of the
soldier
on the ground the combat soldier is to
think uh how things will be perceived
in the media it is his or her job to
make they're applying according to the
laws of armed conflict and international
law of course but it's other people's
job to
make sure how things are portrayed in
the media
so when we talk about the deviation of
responsibility we also talk about
how do we allocate the responsibilities
in terms of short-term
uh considerations and long-term
considerations the soldiers
uh uh job right now is to take into
account the very short-term
considerations he or she needs to
tackle the terrorists in front of her or
in front of him
uh the job of the politicians of the
statesman for example
is to take in consideration the
long-term considerations right all the
things will be perceived in
international tribunals
etc very similar to pandemic the only
difference is that the enemy
here is kind of invisible no you got i
think that that's just
incredibly fascinating because at the
end you have this really fine balance of
the lawmakers and the statesmen who are
thinking about these long-term
regulations and decisions
for example you know the the basic human
rights and and how
war can and should be and should be um
manipulated but then you have people on
the ground and i think the fascinating
thing about
war is that it takes a slight second
or a slight action a move of a button
to really change the landscape and to
change how a country is perceived or or
acts or even survives
and at the end these actions amount to
to huge deals and i'm looking at the
media
as more of a catalyst to to shed light
on these more obscure events that might
not
be seen in a good light in the
international community
so where where where are you headed now
gotti because i can't even follow and i
i want to use the the last few minutes i
have to try and keep up
as long as i have you here um
so as for as for the moment uh my
short so let's divide it into short-term
and long-term
goals in the short term i have to finish
my book
it's about time i'm speaking for about
three years now all over the world uh we
were talking about this before
i was due to the situation in covert 19
i have
like four canceled one of them in japan
and south korea
uh it was a long long time dream of mine
to speak to jewish communities in the
far east
uh but every time i'm engaging with
different communities they're like you
gotta write a book about this and i'm
like i
do i have already i just need to finish
it
um so finish the book uh make some
substantive
progress with my phd i think it's
immensely important to know what you're
talking about
there are a lot of good people with
great great intentions
trying to advocate for the state of
israel uh but
if you don't know what you're really
talking about it's really hard to make a
good case
for your client or for your cause uh
so i'm not you know telling anyone don't
advocate for israel or
do advocate for i'm just saying if you
do want to advocate for a certain cost
you have to study it thoroughly you have
to devote your entire being
for it i'm currently pursuing my fourth
law degree in it and i still
think and no i have a lot to learn
um and besides that look i'm not trying
to sound like a cliche or a new age you
know
uh person but really trying to be happy
in this
environment that you know the situation
created
um it forces you to think about the true
meaning of
of how we live in our lives the true
meaning of a community
um right now we're entering in israel
into the very
the most israeli week in the year
starting with the holocaust memorial day
and ending with the
uh fallen soldiers and terrorist victims
of memorial day in you know
independence day um celebrating this
this events through the the confined
spaces of our own homes make you think
about
what a community is where do i want to
find myself within these communities and
how i want to
spread good within these communities so
this is where my thoughts are for the
long run and uh
i hope to be worthy of you know trying
to fulfill them
so much inspiration over here guys so
much before we leave i i'm gonna put you
on the spot once and i really shouldn't
do that to a lawyer
i'm really shooting myself in the leg
here i'd like you to tell me
um three words that you would best
describe yourself as
or that you would think that you would
want others to describe
goddy as
all right so like every
good lawyer i would say it depends yes
i'll just say it depends on what sphere
you're talking about if it's a
professional sphere i would definitely
say
a speaker a writer
and a lawyer and if on the personal one
a jew okay wow the first one
yeah it's you israeli wow
and um and it has been slash sun
i love it so much thank you so much for
your time
this was fascinating you're the greatest
thank you so much
stay safe